of those little bunny rabbits were
wearing bow ties by the way oh
at school well we got a pat on the back
and a push to the Future for the top
middle school spellers in the Clark
County School District
these six young men and women were
treated to lunch made and served by High
School culinary students over at the
East Career Technical Academy
Stephanie stonex from the CCSD Student
Activities Department the first and
second place sixth seventh and 8th grade
spellers each given plaques made for a
perfect proud family photo opportunity
there you go ask for tips to stay sharp
on spelling 8th grader Isabelle from
rogich middle school said being a good
reader helps and she gave a shout out to
her dad he like gave me some like you
know hard words that he found to spell
like while we were like
eating dinner or something congrats to
all
from Belinda Brown the head of the state
spelling bee which is where these bright
students are headed in March yeah that's
where with dozens of other students from
all over Nevada these kids are going to
find out which one will go on to
represent the Silver State at the
National Spelling Bee later this year
you know we always want to know what's
cool it's cool you got something let us
know cool at school under the Community
tab of our website or just email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com by the way the
head of the states found agree Melinda
Brown said hey if you're somebody out
there with big bucks in the community
that would be willing to help out a
sponsorship could send a second Nevada
student to the national competition
they work so hard and study for this
yeah they deserved at least two to go
yeah
it's tough we didn't do so well
yes yes I'm sure uh yeah it's
challenging to be up there on stage you
have to answer in that time here you
never know anything about that would you
Mr langler no I don't know how
challenging that can be or how
embarrassing